[Música]
porque nos gustan ciertos espacios más
que otros o para tomarnos una fotografía
qué es lo que tienen estos lugares que
los hacen ser especiales para querer
sacar la cámara y capturar el momento
primero estamos buscando un lugar
atractivo un lugar donde nos sintamos
seguros un lugar donde estemos a gustos
viendo y siendo vistos y por supuesto es
un lugar donde vamos a generar una
identificación con el espacio
y cuáles son los beneficios que tiene
esto en una ciudad ustedes sabrán y
habrán visto en otras ocasiones cómo hay
lugares en donde son más atractivos para
que vayan las parejas que se van a casar
o por supuesto los 15 años rusos
fundamental en toda la ciudad vemos las
quinceañeras que escogen lugares
específicos para reflejar una fecha tan
importante y encontramos que un lugar
atractivo también generalmente es un
lugar sano ecológico donde generalmente
hay árboles en los espacios abiertos el
sentirnos seguros lo reflejamos a través
o se refleja a través de la vitalidad
que tiene el espacio de lo vibrante que
es de las actividades que se pueden
realizar ahí el ver y ser vistos
inmediatamente nos coloca a nosotros
también en una posición de ser
observadores naturales del espacio de
controlarlo y de alguna manera también
de cuidarlo porque está
identificación con el espacio también se
convierte en un sentido de pertenencia y
al tener sentido de pertenencia nosotros
cuidamos algo si alguien está rayando le
vamos a decir algo si alguien está
tirando basura probablemente por lo
menos lo vamos a ver con ojos juzgadores
y eso nos ayuda a que las ciudades se
mantengan sin necesidad de que tenga que
encargarse necesariamente de la política
pública simplemente el espacio está
hecho para ser habitado y para ser
cuidado
el cine es esencial para entender estas
estas secuencias para entender lo que
estamos hablando el cine específicamente
estas películas de woody allen en donde
hace de la ciudad un personaje más
podemos ver cómo es indispensable
entender a estos personajes involucrados
dentro de un espacio para relacionar con
lo que nos quiere reflejar el director
en manhattan del 79 podemos ver como la
ciudad se convierte en este espacio
donde pueden platicar en este espacio
donde se vive la ciudad en donde pueden
ir caminando cuatro personas codo a codo
en una banqueta común y corriente
ustedes llegan en monterrey como en que
ven que banqueta pueden ir caminando
codo a codo
generalmente vamos en filita indiano
porque tenemos unas banquetas pésimas y
eso tiene consecuencias en la manera que
se vive la ciudad
después experimento con otras ciudades
después de ir con su enamorada nueva
york/londres ene
este match point después el week y
cristina cristina barcelona' lo vuelve a
hacer siempre son espacios abiertos los
que donde suceden las cosas donde sucede
lo interesante donde sucede la
sociabilización donde suceden las
escenas representativas desde roma con
amor y por supuesto medianoche en parís
donde si no fuera por estas escenas del
protagonista caminando a las orillas del
río sena y para entender está cómo va
absorbiendo la ciudad pues no
entenderíamos exactamente el
posicionamiento que tiene el personaje y
nosotros qué película seríamos
a mí me viene a la mente esta película
del 92 de joel schumacher falling down
donde está el personaje michael douglas
en el carro y se está desesperando es la
primera escena busquen la en youtube la
pueden encontrar seguramente esta el
personaje en el carro hay tráfico no se
mueve nada están por supuesto los
claxons está la contaminación está el
ruido lo refleja también que me recuerda
cualquier escena que podamos tener en la
ciudad yo creo que definitivamente sí
sería nuestra ciudad sobre todo pensando
que somos el primer lugar en choques en
todo el país
y finalmente provocan que el personaje
se salga el carro lo abandone y empiece
a hacer locuras por todos los ángeles
ese es el significativo peso encontrar
cuáles son los valores que tiene una
ciudad y cuáles son los valores que se
reflejan de los mismos
yo creo que cualquiera nos podemos
relacionar con esta fotografía con esta
imagen en gonzalitos a las 7 de la noche
en plena hora pico
qué oportunidades tenemos en ese lugar
de hacer algo interesante absolutamente
ninguno y qué oportunidades tendrá la
gente que va caminando a los lados de
esa gran avenida absolutamente ninguna
oportunidad de hacer algo interesante lo
que quiere decir si lo que quieren es
caminar y salir de ese lugar y si
tenemos un lugar que solamente sirve
como de trayecto y no como destino el
lugar va a estar abandonado y va a ser
propicio que otras cosas sucedan cosas
de gente que no quiere ser vista de
gente que no quiere conocer a nadie que
no quiere saludar a nadie que no quiere
ser visto al final
también tenemos estos otros mini paraíso
son estos oasis dentro de la ciudad
fundidor es uno de ellos
la macroplaza es otro el paseo santa
lucia
es otro de ellos también podemos citar
él
el propio chipinque que
tenemos esta oportunidad de tener este
rodeo de montañas y que tenemos estos
lugares naturales donde podemos
disfrutar de los paisajes que tenemos
aunque cada vez la nata de contaminación
en nuestras ciudades que es presente y
e indivisible pero como podemos movernos
entre uno y otro
generalmente estos lugares están
aislados y qué es lo que los conecta las
calles que no tienen ninguna facilidad
para ser habitadas o para ser
transitadas o para ser por lo menos
vividas desde una perspectiva distinta
que no se habla del automóvil
bueno tenemos estos lugares que están
aislados prácticamente lo que los
articula son
este tipo de calles este tipo de calles
que aunque vayan personas pues quien se
quería quedar en juárez por ejemplo o
sea quien querría que realmente estar
ahí observando en esta avenida sin
embargo un montón de personas la
transitan
pero lugar no lo hace propicio para ser
vivido de otras circunstancias y si
nosotros vemos
como se divide el espacio
pues vamos a encontrar también este tipo
de cosas ya tenemos una desproporción
enorme de lo que queda para los peatones
y lo que queda para los automóviles y
para el transporte público es una
desproporción alarmante y sobre todo
también es una limitación de las cosas
que se pueden hacer en un lugar y otro
por las condiciones físicas del espacio
sin embargo nuestra propia ciudad así de
difícil como la podemos tener también
tiene estos lugares también ha resuelto
la forma de la movilidad de forma
distinta también hemos hecho este tipo
de redes
intervenciones en la ciudad en la que
los árboles son los puntos importantes
de cómo se puede vivir el espacio y los
lugares para sentarse y gracias a esas
personas que se quedan en estos lugares
sentados es que el espacio puede ser
controlado de cierta manera controlado
de forma positiva si nosotros no tenemos
estos lugares para estar los lugares
simplemente servirán de tránsito
este ejemplo es fundamental para ver eso
nosotros no nos podemos localizar en
este punto de la de la macroplaza
volteamos la cámara para un lugar y
vemos en la macroplaza completamente sin
gente no nadie quiere estar ahí nadie
quiere estar bajo el sol y volteando la
cámara al otro lado podemos ver un lugar
que tiene todo lo contrario las
condiciones son completamente distintas
está lleno de personas está lleno de
actividades y que es lo único que varió
los árboles y la sombra y en una ciudad
que llega a 40 grados de temperatura se
entiende y se entiende que debería ser
parte de la lógica de la ciudad y sin
embargo no lo es
los propios edificios públicos podrían
ser la oportunidad para generar estos
espacios distintos estos espacios de
desaceleración donde puedas ir a pagar
el predial y después quedarte sentado y
tomando el fresco hasta que te quieras
ir
ese ritmo acelerado en la ciudad de
alguna manera limita la experimentación
y los movimientos que podemos hacer
dentro de ella
en esta foto es evidente como la sombra
atrae actividades o por lo menos
movimiento y en el otro lado está mucho
más limitado si hubieran entendido eso
los diseñadores de este puente que se
hizo peatonal por completo pues a lo
mejor tendríamos un puente con mucho más
actividades con más vibrante y más vivo
en este punto me gusta cómo se ve el
árbol como si fuera un refugio este mar
de calor que puede llegar a ser esta
ciudad
si entendemos eso es porque no llenamos
entonces de árboles todos los lugares
que tengamos cerca porque no llegan
porque no buscamos la respuesta de
nuestra ciudad a través de la ecología
también
y tal vez se animen serían lugares donde
más gente se quisiera tomar una
fotografía es lo de menos lo de la
fotografía es el vehículo para
comprender cómo los espacios atraen o no
personas y como los espacios te puedes
sentir identificado o no y con lo tanto
atraído no quien ha pasado por félix u
gómez
y colon
entonces como una película de esta de
ciencia ficción con futuros distópicos
en donde solamente hay concreto donde
nadie quiere estar por supuesto la
ecología está completamente fuera de la
ecuación
imagínense estar allí a las 10 de la
noche a las 8 oa las dos de la tarde que
estaba ahí hoy nadie quiere estar ella
no es lugar un su lugar que se le
inseguro por las personas y que no te
atrae por supuesto para nada y también
tiene que ver con cómo esta
infraestructura que es muy necesaria por
supuesto que el transporte público es
esencial para una ciudad del tamaño de
la nuestra y pensar en el transporte
público como una oportunidad también
para que las para que subieran repensado
como un lugar de encuentro que va a
pasar cuando esta línea esté en uso y
toda la gente que viaja en el metro se
quiera bajar en ese lugar por dónde va a
caminar siquiera que va a provocar y
creo que nos falta entender cómo tenemos
la oportunidad para mejorar estas
condiciones de seguridad con todos estos
elementos no nada más con policías
o la propia estación del metro
quién va a querer quedarse de ver en
este lugar quién va a decir nos vemos en
las escaleras de la estación del golfo
nos vemos en la estación del parque
fundidora nop se esperó allá arriba
donde hay gente donde puedo estar
sentado en la escalera ni de chiste y
sin embargo en otros países con
problemas muy distintos pero también muy
similares a los nuestros se ha podido
pensar el metro y las estaciones como un
lugar y como una oportunidad para que
otro tipo de cosas sucedan
esta es una estación de un metro elevado
igual que el nuestro de concreto igual
que nuestro pero haciendo las escaleras
ligeramente más grandes pero no
ligeramente no mucho más grandes para
que por la gente puede esperar y esto
atrae después a que venga el que te
vende café a que venda a que venga el
que vende los cigarros y de alguna
manera se crea una suerte de plaza
alrededor y no nada más esta es donde se
genera eso en todas las estaciones en el
medellín o la mayoría tienen esta
cualidad porque las nuestras tienen que
ser estas escaleras
antes
la iniciativa privada también ha
mostrado que se pueden hacer las cosas
bien marco es el ejemplo perfecto quien
no se ha quedado de ver en la paloma de
marco y que nos da esa oportunidad
simplemente que el arquitecto un genio
legorreta decidió ceder este pedazo a la
ciudad ceder a esa esquina no olvidemos
que desde que ponemos un pie en el
primer escalón ese lugar ya es privado
sin embargo se cede y se convierte en un
icono de las ciudades y se convierte
también en un refugio para los que
caminan por ahí y también nos dé otra
lección muy importante
que las banquetas se pueden volar o sea
tuvo que venir un arquitecto del
distrito federal para decirnos a los
regios que el sol también se puede
cubrir con árboles y que se puede poner
las baquetas imagínense que todos los
arquitectos en monterrey foráneos o no
hubiéramos decidido poner en nuestros
proyectos banquetas perdón árboles en la
banqueta qué ciudad tan distinta
tendríamos y por supuesto mejorar las
condiciones de camín habilidad mejorar
los las las banquetas quitarle los
baches limpiarlas armonizarlas
qué ciudad tan distinta sería
o el propio barrio antiguo
este es una calle típica de barrio
antiguas y son casi todas banquetas
todavía más diminutas de las que podemos
encontrar en el resto de la ciudad
empedradas suponiendo también hasta un
peligro para la gente que va caminando y
que
que por ahí necesita una superficie
mucho más lisa y que si sirve para algo
para poner carros pero donde sirva para
poner carros elimina la posibilidad de
que cualquier otra cosa suceda y esta es
una calle no tan típica del bar del
mismo barrio antiguo en donde otras
cosas pueden suceder gracias a que se
pensó en los árboles se pensó en las
personas se pensó en que se pueda
caminar
y a mí me da mucho gusto poner el
hashtag barrio antiguo en el facebook
con el instagram y sacar todas estas
fotografías que fueron tomadas de la
segunda fotografía de la primera quién
se querría tomar una fotografía y no
estamos hablando de la foto de nuevo
estamos hablando de lo que te provoca
querer tomarte una fotografía una self y
en determinado lugar y de los cambios
positivos que puede haber para una zona
que existe eso
entonces si nos acordamos de este
ejemplo de juárez una calle que sirve
para moverse a pie amontonado y para
circular en transporte privado
y algunos y algunos públicos pero sin
carriles exclusivos ni mucho menos qué
pasaría si empezamos a ver esto como una
oportunidad para empezar a cambiar las
ciudades y para empezar a mostrar como
con una simple ampliación de banqueta
con una simple apuesta a otro tipo de
movilidad y por supuesto pensando en que
si queremos que camine la gente pues le
tenemos que dar sombras entonces eso
también nos provoca que hay un proyecto
ecológico de plantado de árboles y eso
también ayuda a que se limpia el aire
nacional más contaminada del continente
pues es un ganar-ganar por todos lados y
seguramente ahí va a ser un lugar más
atractivo para tomarse una fotografía
y nuestra ciudad tiene un punto super
importante que a veces olvidamos alguien
reconoce cuál es dónde fue tomada esta
fotografía
es el río santa catarina exactamente un
lugar que ya tiene agua que ya tiene
peces que ya tiene aves que ya tiene una
vegetación importante y que no necesita
canchas y no necesita carros y no
necesita hago karts para funcionar
funciona esto
muy bien de esta manera a lo mucho
necesitará unas escaleritas de madera o
una rampa de madera que nos deje
disfrutar este espacio cómo se puede
disfrutar el río ramos en allende
pero no entendemos esa cercanía que
tenemos con el espacio porque está
limitado con dos muros importantísimos
para cualquier persona que son dos
avenidas las dos principales avenidas de
nuestra ciudad constitución y morones
qué pasaría si le diéramos la
vuelta a cómo entendemos este lugar y
cómo podemos disfrutarlo de manera
distinta
y también entender como este se puede
convertir en un eje que divide la ciudad
pero que también puede ser un eje
integrador
[Aplausos]